it's a great show and I enjoyed watching
season 1 streaming in on Amazon Prime
the original series Goliath returns
today 8 episodes released today we had
Billy Bob Thornton and studio to talk
about it yesterday and on season 2 is my
next guest Morris Chestnut good to see
you sir good to see you good to see you
so before we talk about your show uh-huh
let's get into some hoops here look I
know you are a fan of the Lakers Lakers
yes okay and July 1st is a big day it is
actually in Los Angeles it is that's the
day that LeBron James's phone rings and
we assume somebody named bus or magic
will be making a phone call or palinka
or Rob correct couldn t palinka hmm I
don't know I probably put magics first
up when you if you're if you're wooing
LeBron James wouldn't you magic first up
yeah you definitely put magic but who
are they making a call to are they're
making a call to LeBrons agents to him
directly they got the direct call to you
no I think you can put both of them on
the phone you could and then we're not
conferencing levar in right we're not
doing it I think probably be best that
they don't don't conference no
conferences are no conference at all
[Music]
probably not we're talking about this
back right age a little bit prior to you
coming out here that man LeBron coming
here I don't know if he'd want if he'd
want to sign up for any drama anywhere
he goes agreed and this gentleman seems
to have a little bit of that gene in him
yeah it seems to follow him I will say
that it be honest with you I'm not sure
listen LeBron James is incredible
basketball player I'm not sure I would
love him to have him on the Lakers but
I'm not sure how much I want him on the
Lakers okay now follow up there please
okay because I think I mean obviously
the Bron he's a physical freaking he's
been playing strong for 15 years he's
gone to the finals I don't know where
last year's in a row so I don't know if
you've done the math how many seasons
would that equate to like all those
extra Finals games so he has a lot of
tread on the tires and
not sure how long he can play at that
level I mean I know he's a freak but
we're all human at the end and so even
if he does come to the Lakers I don't
want to gut our youth to get him you
know maybe one you know but I was like
Ingram Koosman I like ba I like all the
players but I don't want to gut our
youth to take together well I mean if
it's all it takes is just some some cash
and and then maybe he could teach the
kids a little bit of something even
though levar said locally here that
there's nothing legal artists he's
already taught not that he doesn't think
that LeBron has knowledge right saying
it's all you know all it takes is cash
though because you me they you know they
had bad youth when he went back to
Cleveland and they they they let go of
Wiggins to get someone a veteran and I'm
not sure if LeBron would win I don't
know I mean I'm not sure but LeBron
would want to go into battle with so
much youth on our T interesting so you
know if you have to bring him in if we
sign him for cash because we do have the
money for two free agents and it feels
good great job yeah yeah but if we do if
we do sign LeBron and we do sign George
its LeBron comfortable with that squad
or does he want to ship some youth out
to get another veteran in there well how
about this for a little wrinkle Chris
Brockman tell Morris Chestnut the news
at you that just broke us from Newton is
indeed dropped yeah according to Yahoo
and ESPN Kawhi Leonard wants out of San
Antonio out yeah Kawhi I guess this
Hawaiian and Gregg Popovich were
supposed to meet to see if there was a
future between the two now that that
would add a little bit of a wrinkle just
taking it all in right now to see if
maybe Kawhi would want to go to
Cleveland to join LeBron there you know
friends of mine have brought this up who
are Laker fans that thought that we can
get Kawhi and I would say that there is
no chance in hell that that's going to
happen because listen if I'm San Antonio
am I gonna trade one of the top two
three two-way players in the league
who's still young to the Lakers and have
to face faced him every single year
because there's never a fair trade for a
superstar right
so who would you give up who would you
give up your Lakers for Kauai anybody
they want that's right so who would you
take if you the Spurs that's a great
question I take Kuzma starters that's
four start okay where do we finish it
was the end we finished any deal would
have to include Kuzma Ingram and draft
fix okay so whose mo is basically indeed
it would include Kuzma and Ingram
because we're drafting at number 20 I
don't know it's entirely possible that
Gregg Popovich for whatever reason is
consuming this conversation and laughing
his ass off I mean if I was Popovich I
don't care if you if you offered me the
entire liquor franchise and I got a bag
of chips from someone in the East I'm
not gonna face Kawhi Leonard multiple
times a year in the West I would not
trade him I would not trade him to the
Lakers if I was if I was palpable
so that's what I'm saying that may well
and and Cleveland doesn't have enough
today I mean if he told the Marcus
Aldridge there's no way I'm trading you
because there's no way I'm getting equal
value back for you right then there's no
way like who could possibly be equal
value for Kawhi there's no one there's
no equal value anywhere anywhere but
especially not to the Lakers especially
not if I'm a Laker fan I'm not I'm not
trading anybody to Boston let me ask you
this question Morris Chestnut yes rich I
didn't take you this and let me ask you
this question if you had to give up ball
or Kuzma who's the one that you would
want to hold on to of those two like
your own diss track or kuzmic depends on
it depends on the makeup of the team
you know I personally think that Alonzo
ball has a lot of upside I think that
Kyle Koosman still has more upside as
well who's great that's a tougher rich
man you hit me with these tough
questions so early in the morning um
while ball or Kuzma I probably I
probably would give up Kuzma see I go
the opposite way
why don't but why because I don't want
Lavar ball anywhere near my franchise
okay so you didn't say lebar ball a lot
of was part and parcel you could sit
here and say he's just noise and don't
pay attention to him or whatever
at some point he will say something that
requires a phone call from any of the
aforementioned members of management to
him right or some sort of statement from
the team to the media to say we're all
good right and to me III but then again
I'm not around the team and I'm not
seeing how this manifests itself
everyday I'm just responding to what I
see in the media well let's look at
let's look at last year so last year he
came out and he made the statement about
the team wasn't following they weren't
behind Luke Walton right yes he made
that statement I think the team
performed for it very well behind Luke
Walton we put on a winning streak right
after that it felt like the team came
closer together after he made that
statement but wouldn't you want the team
just to come closer together just
because of Luke Walton rather than the
fact look maybe Lavar balls to have
something I think that they were gonna
come together where they'll evolve all
say that or not because I think Luke
Walton is doing a great job and he's
progressing the team forward I'm saying
that to say that I don't think that that
statement affected the team negatively
Morris Chestnut here on the Rich Eisen
sure at Morris underscore chestnut well
back in 60 seconds Brockman the the rare
Laker eagle yes that's very it's a
rarity yes it's like a go for years I'm
not a bad way but diamond in the rough
I'm not a bandwagon and then we'll talk
some Goliath with Morris Chestnut when
we come back Morris Chestnut another
segment with him here Reggie Bush making
his way to the studio will hang out with
him in our number three yeah your team
to USC Lakers and eagles so basically
the Eagles was something long time I
used to like the way when they wear the
cutoff jerseys I just played Pop Warner
football we had cutoff jerseys and at
that time the Eagles with woman
Montgomery Harold Carmichael they play
with coffers you saw it was a fan ever
since then they got Randall Cunningham
then Donovan McNabb and I just been a
fan ever since so you are legit people
always ask me I am legit I can tell you
how I'm legit because prior to this year
the Eagles have never won a Super Bowl
so if I'm gonna be a bandwagon what am i
bandwagon for that's true but now you're
just saying it in 2008
no documents UNICEF Jordan you can call
Seth I've been to Eagles game back when
name is Seth join it was Seth to honor
his old school when he was playing with
the Eagles I was energy was why he was
out there yeah I'm telling you that's
that I'm funny cuz he was he I was
telling you this too he and Ken Norton
jr. were the first analysts that I
worked with on the NFL Network we the
three of us did so many NFL Total Access
together and anytime I wanted to get
under Seth skin which you know I had to
tread lightly I was about to say keep
things lively you know anytime I died I
would mention the name rich coat tight
and it would be red flag in front of a
pole he would just he would just see red
and he Seth would disappear and out
would come the guy that you probably saw
every Sunday oh wow let me tell you
something you used to get under Stef
skin Seth I think at the time that I met
Seth he was literally the biggest human
being that I ever met yeah he was about
this what it was I mean he was huge huge
he still is no yeah it still is yeah I
saw him I think not last season but
season before that so the Eagles wanted
on the Eagles wanted all you had to be
beyond beside that was my son and my son
and I were at the game you freezing your
ass off I was zero degrees on the
warmest moment of that day get even
getting into the stadium yeah it was it
was really cold but luckily it was for a
good cause
have we not have one not probably to
ride it there in Minnesota but we wanted
so it was cool so all things being equal
and everybody's healthy Wentz wins yes
okay definitely even - Thank You Nick
for for that incredible run well I think
that Nick had an incredible run and
people other people say well you know
could carson wentz have had that run I
got to be honest I'm not sure how many
quarterbacks from any team in the NFL
could have had that run at that time we
went against the number one Vikings
defense and then we went against the
Patriots and Tom Brady winced had to I
mean I went foals had two incredible
games crowd
incredible games and I'm not sure I mean
there's this briefs have that game he
didn't have it the week before against
Minnesota when he played um does does
anybody but Brady have those types of
games and you know foals had two great
games but you have to give it back to
win yeah I mean - yeah I mean undrafted
undrafted free agent Corey Clement yeah
that kid was in crying we had him on the
on the set a week later just it was just
neat meeting him he's from C's from
South Jersey from southern New Jersey
okay
across the across the way yeah see they
got the rings last night I did serious
bling I was disappointed I didn't I
didn't get mine for decades I need I
need a ring there it is right there look
at right now hold on I don't have my
shades here 219 diamonds and seventeen
sapphires that isn't the edge of the dog
inside - that's gonna be the challenge
we you know we took the underdog label
and we put that chip on our shoulder I
think now I think they're gonna be
players like noise so what Carson Wentz
you have Darren Sproles Thomas our
tackle and a linebacker Jordan so they
weren't able to participate in that game
so I think we're has some pretty good
positions with people age I think
they're they're the favorites to win the
NFC again you do I do I know a lot of
people are really high on the Rams here
and for good reason yeah very good
reason they're very talented and they
should put together and we might see the
Eagles Rams game that we that was an
incredible game that one obviously that
not Wentz out for the season was in the
Coliseum it was it's a fun game we might
was that I wonder if did can you look up
did Kevin Hart get a ring from the no
keV he's a huge fan
he predicted to let the 162 to 5 final
scores somebody predict oh yeah yeah yes
I'm out there for sure yeah trout Mike
Trout mighta got one go see I don't know
I was just trying to stir it up sir you
are in Goliath season 2 season 1 is
tremendous Billy Bob Thornton and the
rest of the rest you were just learning
that as well yes what was the experience
like for you it was a great experience
you know Billy I took the show I was on
the show got canceled then they called
and said hey would you you want to be on
a season look live and I took the show
Strictly before because I want to work
with Billy and he was great he's a
tremendous actor but he's a great
storyteller he has so many stories about
acting about his childhood everything
and I just it was just great being on
set I'll just come said just listen to
his stories and so what what to expect
from your character your is it basically
gonna be a ton of you butting heads with
the Billy Bob character but not
definitely butt heads and he always does
this like what he's doing right there
he's just so you know he's know these
little things that just really get under
your skin but yes we butt heads and then
it
I think episode 7 I'm not sure if I can
remember it kind of comes to a head okay
yeah well that's I know what I'm doing
this weekend really enjoyed season one
yeah it was great really enjoyed it in
season two Billy Bob was talking it up
yesterday I'm yeah yeah he's great he's
real that you are in it as well thank
you and and it's been a long time since
like Mike man we'll see where we are so
be like LeBron is that what it would be
like the Bronco be Mike you know like
Lonzo you said yes you big Lonzo because
I wanna hear me out
a young man puts on a pair of big baller
brand shoes suddenly plays like Lanza
how does levar not want to get in
Branka produces since obviously he and
he's coming away like levar said look
look I am I am a huge lousy ball fan I
think alonso has a very bright future I
agree and you know and I think that he
played well last year despite all
distractions I
there's no she wouldn't that be honestly
one of the greatest things
Lonzo gets traded to Gregg Popovich and
Popovich is the one who handles the
Lavar ball scenario and however he
chooses I don't think that's what I do
not think that that could man let's make
this a regular thing coming down
definitely I have an NBC show coming out
I'm gonna call the enemy with this I'll
come back let's go back in uh February
in February celebrate the back-to-back
Super Bowl win I'll celebrate the
back-to-back Super Bowl win and that's
when our show comes that's what I show
here okay
all right before that just cause okay
I'm local Morris Chestnut is here at
Morris underscore Chestnut be one of the
1.5 million on his Twitter account and
then of course check out Goliath
streaming available right now on Amazon
Prime the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience